am 8 september 2016 fand der sechzehnte
wien energie business run statt
auch heuer haben wieder 30.000
sportbegeisterte an den bewerbungen
laufen und nordic walking teilgenommen
das bundesministerium für
landesverteidigung war mit 1350 jedes
angehörigen vertreten
bei dieser sportveranstaltung stehen
teamgeist und das gefühl des
miteinanders im vordergrund
im ersten block starteten der
spitzenläufer die einen kilometer in
weniger als vier minuten laufen dann
folgten jeweils im abstand von vier
minuten
die blogs mit 500 läufern die 1350
bundesheer läufer starteten in einem
blog die neuenburger starteten ab 1954
die vier kilometer lange strecke führte
vom ernst happel stadion über die
stadion alle die lust haus straße und
über die prater hauptallee zurück ins
stadion nach einer dreiviertel in der um
den rasen war die zielgerade vor dem
stadion erreicht
so bestimmen und ist eine wartehalle
widerstandes sein traum gewesen
ein cooles fehler nicht das letzte mal
aber das ist mein erstes mal dabei zu
sein ist eine gute gefühle mit leute
freuen der kameraden und ein kommandant
sein und das hat so viel spaß macht
erstes mal statt
dabei schauen mal wie ein stadium läuft
heute war so laut dass eine sehr gute
gefühle normalerweise kenntnis nur voll
als zuschauer von oben und dann rennt
man da rein unten die musik oder viele
leute das ist super die als psychologin
nehmen doch das sicherlich irgendwas mit
von diesem erlebnis also im teamgeist
auf alle fälle das sieht man auch ganz
schön bei uns das wirklich auch die
leute vom bundesheer gemeinsam gelaufen
sind und ein team eine einheit gebildet
haben
und nächstes jahr sieht man sicher
wieder dabei das ding des bundesheeres
souverän gewonnen
wir waren froh dass man den titel aus
dem vorjahr verteidigen kennen wir mal
ausgehen von anfang an eher und freuen
uns natürlich sehr
es ist jedes jahr wieder schön zu sein
form jetzt im zweiten jahr dass man das
kind haben kann dass man von anfang an
aus kontrollieren und es ist super
aufgegangen und haben uns alle gut
also seien gut gelaufen es gibt ja
glauben trainings unterschiede wofür
dieses rennen für ein anderes rennen
bestimmt wir sonst gewonnenen wahl zu
laufen und laufen und auch vier
kilometer nur auf asphalt saß ihr
bislang spezielle vorbereitung damit der
beinmuskulatur das eher gewohnt einander
verkaufen dann ist es bringt auch so da
haben sie durch die andere trainings
vorhaben das im grunde gleich also wie
gesagt wir seien im grund auf weichem
untergrund zu laufen und wenn man so
kurz wettkampfes faktor macht das team
das wir aber kürzere intervalle auf
harten untergrund laufen und das hat sie
heute glaube ich ausgesagt für uns und
die gegend um stadion ist doch schön und
so offen und so eher oder parkt ein
im prozess habe sondern
orientierungslauf erinnert aber es ist
schon ein kompletter unterschied
wir wollen ja letztes jahr sieger in der
firmenwertung gut das war eine große
motivation
das hat zu wiederholen ich habe ganz
kleines team die arbeiten super sind
voll motiviert und da haben wir wirklich
wieder was auf die beine gestellt kann
stolz sein und diese mitarbeiter kann
man sie vermeiden ja sie sind voll
motiviert und immer wieder versuche
meister machen immer wieder besser
werden dass das macht wirklich aus
die ersten drei plätze im 4100 meter
bewerb wurden von robert merlo gernot
kerschbaumer und matthias einer belegt
somit die auch die teamwertung an das
österreichische bundesheer
herr
frag ich es von der partei zu mehr
treffer
in solchen fällen zwar frei und
natürlich heftigen applaus bekommt